[Music]
hello Stewart is a pleasure to have you
here today thank you how are you doing
well cool so typically we would start
these with a question asking the
students how many of you use flat but
since it's the official communication
platform for the GSB we're gonna have to
do something a little different how
about a game of to truth in a lot cool
so up here on the screen in just a
second we're gonna see three statements
that I pulled from my extensive research
of your past we're gonna add the ask the
audience to guess which one of them is a
why so statement one you were born with
the name Stewart Butterfield okay
statement two you have two philosophy
degrees alright statement three Flickr
your first successful startup was
conceived while battling with food
poisoning okay so with the audience
raise your hand if you think statement
one is false oh wow it's a lot of people
raise your hand if you think statement
two is false okay raise your hand if you
think statement three it's false
okay let's do it people are pretty good
it's number one it's number one so you
were not born Stewart Butterfield I was
born Dharma Jeremy Butterfield to hippie
parents in a little town called London
British Columbia which is literally the
end of the road so Pacific Coast Highway
is the same Road that goes all the way
down to Chile and then all the way up to
where the few words in British Columbia
and the fact that there's no relate
there's no people living any further
north means that it was foolish to
continue building the road so we're
there and grew up in a log cabin it for
the first couple years grouping I love
cabin
Abe Lincoln also grew up in the LOC area
yeah that's why I bring it up for the
positive associations yeah so trust me I
understand my parents named me Traverse
key Thailand Gerrit and as a four year
old I was not writing for Dvorsky on
every spelling test so I go by Thailand
and
actually no me about time yeah so why is
very soon when I was twelve I really
wanted to be normal and for some reason
I thought Stuart was a normal name like
Mike and Hertz that's a pretty bad name
like you'll notice this after I say it
any time you watch a movie TV show
there's a character named Stuart there's
like the jerk version and then there's
like the sad-sack kind of loser person
I'm never like we've never protagonists
with the exception of the mouse Stuart
Little
that was one of my favorite movies
growing up so if you could pick any name
today what would it be it would be
Dharma Jeremy Butterfield it's a
secondary school so you you handed a
little bit on your parents what have
been the most lasting influences from
their parenting style oh that's a good
question I mean it's hard to it's hard
to separate out that from what life
would have been without those influences
my mom is incredibly supportive to the
extent that when I was 16 I got in a car
accident just totaled the car my dad's
car and my mom's reaction was well it's
really good that you did that because do
you learn an important lesson about
driving safety which is not the reaction
I was expecting my dad was a real estate
developer and real estate development it
usually works the people incorporate a
new entity for each project or each
development maybe there's a management
company it takes management fees but
kind of isolates the the investments
which means that it's like great you
know creating a business over and over
again like every two or three years
there's a fundraising cycle and there's
kind of putting together the vision and
a plan and then over the next decade or
so that that plays out so I think that
was a big influence for me just because
I got to see the development of I don't
even know but you know over the course
my my childhood once I was aware of what
was going on maybe five or six different
businesses and that was
good practice cuz I think I've started
looking at the world that way that's
cool that's cool so you were born
Dharma Butterfield you were raised by
parents who aspire to live off the land
it only makes sense that you would be
drawn to technology so what led you to
teach yourself to program at the age of
seven computers were just so cool and
even look you know you see now any three
month or six month of love is just drawn
to the iPad in a way that seems like it
must be indicative of like a lower level
brain function that was hijacked in
order to be attracted to this so for me
any menu screen just like you know any
child any screen was a super attractive
but the idea that you could control what
appeared was really magical and
1979-1980
somewhere around there I got an Apple TV
at home so we had one in the classroom
for the very first class at my school to
have a computer in the classroom and I
would buy a copy of a magazine called
bite which in the back a couple of pages
had programs and you can just type out
yourself in an apple basic and you can
change a couple things and see what
happened and it was really have
difficulty
describing like why it had such a
powerful hold but what was interesting
is if you fast forward but you know 20
years there was yeah I liked I had an
early game console called me on
television it's a liked video games like
most boys my age there was a arcades
where you went and put quarters and
machines and stuff like that but
computers themselves became less and
less interesting to me over the course
of high school but when I got to college
I got an account on the school's UNIX
machine and discovered the internet this
was 1992 and that was just totally
mind-expanding
and I almost couldn't believe that such
a thing was possible and had but like
the same feeling of wonder but to a
higher degree because it was like we as
a species have developed the ability to
transcend geography in a much more
profound way than like long-distance
phone calls out or the Telugu
you could find community I grew up in
its going to college in Victoria British
Columbia which is again on the edge of
the continent very remote kind of
provincial and you could find people who
are interested in exactly what you were
anywhere in the world and that
communication was happening at the speed
of light so that really opened up and
then fast forward another ten years so
like in the early 2000s that had this
experience finally where I had my laptop
with me and what at one point in my life
had been like the Steve Jobs bicycle for
the mind like this incredible machine
that mean anything was possible and all
this amazing software when it wasn't
connected to the internet was inert it
was basically kind of useless it was
like a rock so it's a very interesting
experience to think about like the
successive layers of what really matters
the first one being that ability to run
arbitrary code so to generate more or
less anything that a human can imagine
and then the ability to put all of those
together and I think that was but the
thing that has guided my career ever
since is the exploration of that idea of
computing technology as a means of
facilitating human interaction it's
amazing so that's what drew you to
technology initially but you actually
studied philosophy so what inspired that
decision I really wanted to do degree in
cognitive science but the school that I
went to didn't have cognitive science so
it was cognate science is usually
computer science psychology linguistics
and psychology and so I wanted to take
courses and all four to do an honours
degree in psychology was like every
single course was requirement in fact
you had to do like extra whereas
philosophy it's pretty light set of
requirements I'm even to do an honours
degree so I chose philosophy literally
like that it was like the of those four
the one that had the few miss
requirements but after I started
studying it even though I suck it was
really a de philosophie of mine is
really interested in neuro psych as an
undergrad
fundamentals of philosophy I found super
fascinating and this is this sounds bad
and it is bad in one sense and it's good
in another sense so you think about last
2,500 years of kind of the history of
inquiry of all different kinds at some
point everyone was a philosopher but if
you were interested in the world in an a
religious way so like the beginnings of
science
it was philosophy at some point
mathematics geometry astronomy split off
over the next many hundred years
things like biology in the 19th century
split off into its own discipline and
psychology anthropology sociology
computer science linguistics women's
studies until all you had left was like
an area of inquiry that is not directed
at anything except for like itself and
language so in one sense it's really
boring so if you didn't ever study
philosophy and you pick up a book of
like contemporary anglo-american
analytic philosophy it is super super
boring like it's almost impenetrable
without like this giant vocabulary of
ways to get into it but once you're into
it I still find it really fascinating
because there's so many unanswerable
questions it's good to know so who was
the most influential philosopher to you
I have a pretty broad range and I liked
all kinds of thinkers but like going
back to Aristotle it was a more
contemporary Klein and Donald Davidson
but if there was one it was Victor slack
because that's why I ended up going to
Cambridge amazing amazing so we're in
1997 now you're armed with two
philosophy degrees and the name fit for
a philosopher Butterfield but you
decided to become a web developer what
led you back into technology well so
like I said I got to college in 92 which
is like like at least for my awareness
six months to maybe a year before the
web really took off like I think
had been invented but wasn't really
widely deployed so the internet was
email IRC a unix program called talk
more than anything else it was Usenet
and that meant that as soon as the web
became a popular medium that started to
supplant in things like gopher and ways
I was there and it was really the HTML
back then was just dead simple so very
easy to teach yourself so 93 I was one
of five people in my hometown who knew
HTML which meant that 94 95 96 every
year my my my summer job but also just
my job training the school year was
making websites for people who didn't
know how to make websites cuz pretty
much no one did and it was like 98 I
finished my masters and was enrolled in
the PhD and there was the beginning so a
friend of mine had just finished his PhD
in philosophy and I went to a great
school and did great thesis work and it
was really look at the top of the range
and got his first job which was at the
University of Louisville in Kentucky and
he really didn't want to live in
Kentucky and it was a crappy job with
low pay and it's a sessional position so
renews every nine months and I thought
of how many hoops I had to jump through
just to get to that point or because it
was 98 and the.com thing that's starting
to take off and I knew the web and all
of my friends who were like early web
people were moving to San Francisco and
getting jobs that paid 2 or 3 times as
much and it was exciting dynamic and
we're changing the world so I had advice
from a couple professors over the course
of my career who essentially were this
is a terrible life please don't become
an academic if you're interested in this
stuff you can subscribe to the journals
and attend the conferences you don't
have to actually do a PhD and then go be
a professor okay that's good to know
so I'm actually curious raise your hand
if you have a humanities degree okay
keep your hand raised if you're
considering a career in technology
okay so my question there is what were
the advantages and disadvantages and
having a humanities degree and within
the technology industry it's tough
because I mean there's there's multiple
technology industries so when I would
say when I started in 98 like the the
web was tech but it was populated much
more by people with a background in like
graphic design or architecture if you're
making web development the serious
back-end programmers had a parallel
track to web server development but it
was really like a totally different era
and there there wasn't anything in
between like the architects in the
graphic designers on one side and the
people this won't be a familiar
reference to many of you but the people
using web logic and ATG dynamo and these
like from today's contemporary
perspective kind of really horrible
application servers that had
fundamentally different approach to
doing web development some stateful
applications things like enterprise
javabeans and I don't think it really
made any difference what your background
was at that point it could have been
history could have been finance it
could've been physics and meanwhile
there's a different technology in G
which is like all of the descendants of
Fairchild Semiconductor and you know
Intel and HP and a bunch of companies
that were you know native to to this
area but that was completely different
like it would you know the design of
circuit boards and and processors and
manufacture computers was totally
unrelated to the web and still today I
think we say tech industry broadly I
think mostly what people mean is at
least around the bay area is companies
that receive VC backing as opposed to
anything else they're not necessarily
specifically technology companies and
the you know the side effect of software
meeting the world in the famous Marc
Andreessen phrase is that every company
is a technology company so you can look
at like I don't know Visa or MasterCard
probably employ close to an order of
magnitude more software developers than
stripe
I know everyone would say stripe isn't
as a technology company is PayPal a
financial services company or tech
company is Airbnb a tech company or a
hospitality company it's really it
becomes increasingly hard to to make
that distinction unless you mean like
technology is huawei making 5g antenna
chips and it's like now and then
software businesses like flock thank you
for that
so you worked as a web designer for a
few years before starting a video game
company and launching your first video
game game never ending what was your
vision for that game so when I said 92
the thing that was most interesting to
me about the internet was Usenet using
that as a those of you who don't know at
a hierarchical directory of news groups
and it would covered more or less
everything so they began with the
three-letter abbreviation so SCE I was
science and there was science physics
and geology and so on and then rack rack
music Dodd rec type music got G Dead
Grateful Dead was in 92 the the Netflix
of its time in the sense that it used
more bandwidth than any other single
thing on the Internet
there's so much traffic of people
discussing Grateful Dead that it kind of
just surpassed everything else so 93 I
guess probably a year later I had the
first experience of having a crush on
someone that I had never actually met
was just like from her online persona
her cig files the things she said in
comments and the the idea that that kind
of connection was possible was I mean
this really early stage but it's like
was very interesting to me you go
forward to 98 99 2000 and people had
blogs there were the early social
networks like 6 degrees and then
Friendster was probably 2002 ish around
there but people had started developing
a persona and having interactions with
other people over the Internet in a
bunch of different virtual communities
some of those are really explicit like
the well like
the ancient ones but bulletin board
systems discussion boards mousse kind of
like interactive chat based games and
the yeah I said earlier that the idea of
social interaction mediated by computing
technology lent from the new
possibilities that opens up was a thing
that's really fascinating to me
so when you say game I think people have
the assumption that there's puzzle games
and there's shooting games and they're
sports games and stuff like that this
was none of those and this was just play
as a pretext for social attraction so
this is a description that may or may
not have appeal to some of you I will
tell you that it does not have broad
commercial appeal and that's a fist like
whimsical world of like absurdist humor
and kind of hopefully delightful little
things to discover but it's mostly like
a venue for people to interact in to and
to form community with one another and
super popular among the small group of
people for whom we we develop this
prototype and we're testing it but that
was 2002 so some of you are probably
just a little babies in 2002 but there
was the dot-com crash which started in
2000 there was the WorldCom and Enron
accounting scandals there was 9/11 it
was just like a really dark time for
financial markets the nasdaq goes down I
think 80 or 85 percent from its peak so
the S&P 500 thousands 65% it's kind of
like hard to imagine you know even in
comparison to 2008 so no one wanted to
invest in internet stuff period but
definitely no one wanted to invest in
web-based massively multiplayer games it
was just like as frivolous as you could
possibly be which meant that no one
would invest in us and we didn't have
enough money to finish it and we tried
to cast around for something that we
could do with the technology we
developed that would create a
commercially viable product that turned
out to be flubber yeah so ironically
game never ending dead end so how did
you feel when you realized you had to
shut down the game but you know at the
same time they kind of happened like we
were developing Flickr
in the game's side-by-side for a couple
months the decision to make Flickr and
then its launch was you know that's
three months separating those so it
happened pretty quickly but in that case
you know felt like he was a there's a
path forward the team got to stay
together we had I think disappointed a
lot of people who are playing it but
also a lot of them were like look cool
Flickr is interesting too and they're
just kind of migrated so that wasn't
that bad it's good so you realize you
have to shut down the game but not
before flying to one last video game
conference in New York what happens next
so it was a conference on law and
virtual worlds and it's in New York and
I'm from Vancouver where I was living
and got food poisoning on the flight and
don't make it too vivid but it's just
like puking in the immigration Hall at
JFK puking in the cab on the freeway get
to the hotel and like step out of the
cab and puke all over the carpet though
so sorry a little vivid but like I I
couldn't keep down to anything ginger
ale water and that night at like 3:00 in
the morning after being up and kind of
feverish and frantic rode out the whole
first version okay like then what I
would what it would be and how I would
take advantage of those technologies I
will say this though that was the very
first version which is very different
than one and I'm becoming and was not
actually very good that got us going
so I've and yet to have a battle with
food poisoning be so productive so kudos
to you there you decided to focus on
Flickr when you made that shift did
everyone on your team by in immediately
or what was that process like no we so
I'm pretty democratic leader sometimes
maybe less so now than been back then
but we had a vote and there was a tie so
I called Eric Costello it's actually one
of the founders of slack as well
and just like to some background
lobbying to get him to change his vote
so that we could go ad with it there's
definitely like there's people who are
still interested in making the game and
felt like it was a shame to leave it
behind it was also I think in terms of
the number of people online way too
early the technology that was available
way too early like I think people forget
2002 was the first year that any country
about more than 50% entertained Internet
penetration at home and that was the
Netherlands so and even then that was
almost all dial-up connectivity so most
Americans didn't have internet access if
they did it was at work and it was very
kind of narrowly prescribed and if they
did anything online it was like maybe
check sports doors and stock prices or
something like that so there wasn't
really a market for it but um you know I
just like making software just in the
same way that I did when I was seven
years old and I think everyone else on
the team did too so we just got to make
different than a software and in the end
it was you know the game was play as a
pre-tax or social interaction Flickr was
photography as a pretext for social
interaction is the first actually one of
the we got bought by Yahoo and one of
the designers they are called it
massively multiplayer photo sharing
which I thought was pretty accurate cuz
there's a first thing other than web
shots which I heard about later where
you could put a photo online and people
could see it and comment on it and they
could have a title and description and
you could tag it and create groups and
all that kind of stuff so it was a
social network that revolved around and
photographs this is like I think it's we
started right around the same time
Facebook but Facebook was still you know
just in Harford for another six months
or a year and then just IVs for another
close to a year after that cool so not
to spoil the story but you eventually
sell Flickr to Yahoo for excess of 20
million dollars
I'm curious looking back now as you're
leading slack what lessons from your
time at Flickr have been most
influential on the leader that you are
today it's it's hard to say because it
was so long ago like we started
developing in 2003
launched in 2004 and this summer site
that winter break and look 2004-2005
there's this big decision about whether
we're gonna take me Z funding we're
gonna get popped by Yahoo
so this 2005 to 2008 that I was there
and like it's there's definitely not
something that stands us like the thing
that I learned there other than how hard
it is too hard it is to get something
done or how hard it is I mean maybe
that's that is a good lesson how hard it
is to get something done in an
organization of that size because yeah I
was about 12,000 people and I think
there's a couple things that weren't
wrong with it at that time but the
biggest one was it had basically stopped
growing and in an environment where the
pie isn't growing anymore suddenly the
the kind of game theoretic but the
calculus especially among executives is
very zero-sum so it was like people
battling each other
internally but even to forget that for a
second any company of any organization
of 10,000 people and it's requires such
an extraordinary injection of a will to
make anything happen that most things
are for all practical purposes
impossible okay so with fast forward to
2012 you have left Yahoo which by the
way if you have not read the stewards
resignation letter from Yahoo please
google it he likens himself to a 10
Smith there named Brad it's quite
hilarious so as 2012 you're starting
another video game company this time
tiny speck a tiny speck you launch a
game called glitch what gave you more
confidence in the gaming area this time
around so in 2009 that we started the
company in 2012 so maybe we should have
down but it's the same group of people
you know so four of us who hadn't worked
on Flickr and we all work to yeah who
together but 2002 to 2009 was pretty
amazing time in the history of the
internet so suddenly everyone had
internet access
and there were funds that were capable
of internet access there's blackberries
and trios and there were a lot of people
had high-speed Internet by that time the
world of open-source software
specifically to support development on
the internet we had just exploded so
there was really not much available in
2002 but by 2009 we had a very robust
mature Apache foundation and all of
these great networking technologies
people's computers are much faster and
there's many more people online we were
much more experienced it was very easy
to raise monies look if you could just
like look at any factor in a giant
matrix of like things that would lead
this to be a good plan or to be
successful we had shifted from like a 2
out of 10 to an 8 9 or 10 out of 10
except that that idea was still not very
commercially viable same idea like
better graphics do you think do you
think that idea is ever gonna be
commercially so not I mean we could have
kept going and paid all of our salaries
and been happy and it would have been
interesting but we had taken by that
point like 17 million dollars in BC
money so I felt like it would have been
an aberration of the responsibility in
the kind of contract we made with them
to to just do that so we had to think of
someone else
so he said seventeen and a half million
and funding you had you were around 45
employees around the time so you find
yourself in a familiar situation and you
have to shut down that game again what
was the toughest part about that
decision the second time around so the
second time around that was very
different because it wasn't just hey
everyone we we are now as a group in a
switch were working on because there was
animators and musicians and writers and
illustrators level designers a whole
bunch of people who just didn't have
skills that were transferable to does
log so a lot of people are going to get
laid off I think there was 35 and in the
three half years that we have been
running the the various versions of
there wasn't pretty look pretty strong
and very active robust community that
wasn't like a couple hundred people who
tested gave never-ending could just
start using Flickr they they were gonna
disappear and I think this is a hard
thing to relate to or understand if you
haven't gone through it and it's it's
maybe somebody that hasn't happened in a
long time and might not happen again
like tumblr seems like the last platform
that had closed communities like that
whereas now everything like Instagram is
just one world connected to Facebook as
a model world Twitter is like everyone
and there Beth Lee sub-communities but
when communities exist into one specific
platform and that platform disappears
it's a little bit like that moment in
the first Star Wars when Alderaan gets
blown up like it's just that society
that little culture those relationships
just won't exist anymore so it's really
look that was very sad but obviously for
me the video it's personal it's
embarrassing I did all this press and
they made all these claims I had to
convince all these people to calm and it
convinced anytime we got any press it
was my head convinced I'm gonna doing it
every time we've got invested might
convince my to do it but more day in El
Sayed convinced all these people to come
work on this and I told the story many
times but the the day that I made the
announcement internally it called this
All Hands and people already a little
bit apprehensive cuz we've been through
a couple of different like here's the
last thing we're gonna try
there's wasn't a day when we normally
had an All Hands and I locked eyes with
someone as soon as they started talking
who about two or three months before I
had convinced to move to a new city with
his wife and two-year-old daughter away
from where his in-laws lived and the
months were helping to take care of the
kid he moved to new city bought a house
and I was gonna tell him that he didn't
have a job anymore
it was really really hard I mean I think
that's the like the impact on me
reputationally or financially was in the
grand scheme of things in relatively
insignificant like I would just bounce
back again but it's that's more than
just disappointing someone like
was gonna come meet you for dinner and I
bailed with the last minute or something
like that this is like I convinced you
to change the alter of the course of
your life in a really significant way
and then didn't it didn't happen so that
was very very difficult in Indiana needs
like a little bit of positive news
because we had five and a half million
dollars left of that money we were able
to shut down in a relatively elegant way
so we made a portfolio site which had
everyone's resumes and did a bunch of
reference letter writing and kind of
career coaching and helped get everyone
a job but in most cases a better job
than they had when they were working for
us and we were able to give customers
the choice of their money back when we
could donate it in charity or whatever
but um and that one person Tim Lafleur
ended up joining slack [ __ ] a year
later so that part all worked out too
but doesn't mitigate at all like what it
felt like in that moment it was really
it was pretty terrible that's that's
pretty heavy so how did you go from that
terrible moment to launching slack which
reached a billion dollar valuation and
record-setting pace of eight months that
worked out super well I mean we had
developed the system that was the proto
slack again ninety-two I mentioned one
of the software network tools that I
used was called IRC or Internet Relay
Chat and we used IRC that ties back the
company they made glitch and it's a very
old technology so it's with most
messaging systems that probably every
messaging system you've ever used
there's a concept in what's called
store-and-forward so i'm if i want to
send a message to you but I can't reach
you right now like there's no connection
to your endpoint your client or your
device it'll just be held and then
forwarded to you the next time you
connect but IRC didn't have that if you
weren't connected at the moment that I
sent the message you would just never
receive it so he built the system to log
the messages but once we had the
messages in database you wanted to be
able to search them so we build search
on top of that and then like bit-by-bit
kind of feature by feature we build
things to integrate with our files
when someone uploaded the file and would
get announced into IRC or feh
an alert went off in our data center
then that would get put into IRC and
slowly we developed a system which was
like really the foundation of all of the
ways in which the company communicated
and was really beneficial and so we
realized huh none of us are ever going
to work without something like this ever
again other teams of eight software
developers would probably like it as
well and so we decided that's what we're
gonna do and we thought that one day in
the fullness of time if we had every
single person who could possibly use
this we would have a hundred million
dollars in revenue and thereby be a
billion dollar company and that just
happened definitely checks out
so what's slack you created a product
that not a lot of companies knew they
needed how did you convince him
otherwise that was tough the first first
like three or four external teams to use
slack it took dozens of tries like going
to their office and showing them and I
think we learned a lot there about
marketing probably isn't the right term
but you know I think we actually had
this problem a little bit with liquor
because Facebook came out and just stole
the social photo sharing market while
Flickr was trying to decide whether it
wanted to be social photo sharing or
like a community for people who are
interested in photography but if you
can't explain what you're doing well
enough that someone to whom you explain
it can go on to explain it to someone
else then it's a real problem because
otherwise otherwise you're gonna have to
do all the explaining
so we struggled to figure out the way to
talk about it like what advantages it
had what it was for but when you're when
it's net new and it's not replacing
something else it's very difficult
there's um I don't know if it's still
frequently read but there's a classic
book in in marketing called positioning
Jack trout and Alan Reece I think and
one of these I talk about is if
something's a new concept for you it's
almost impossible for it to get purchase
in somebody's brain in somebody's mind
so you have to find something else that
they that already exist there and
then alter that idea which is why you
here Lewbert for whatever because if you
had to explain the whole thing from
scratch it's just very difficult it's
why you hear like movie pitches that are
you know jaws meets Star Wars or
something like that and it's much easier
to get that than to start from scratch
but it was like it was a real slob to
get anyone to even try it and the
incursian thing was once people started
trying it they all mostly variably stuck
with that they've logged in every day it
became like it was for us the foundation
of how they communicated and so from
2014 to 2017 there was limited
competitors for slack given that it was
such an innovative idea but in 2017 when
slack had more than 100 million in
revenue which you predicted 650
employees and evaluation of around five
billion dollars Microsoft launched their
teams at how did you feel when you found
out that app was coming out I think
mostly just good because it would
validate the idea and we had some
advance notice that it was coming we
worked with Microsoft on some early
stuff with Microsoft Research on
building question-answering BOTS for
first lock and had a pretty good
relationship with a guy named Qi Liu who
was a software exactly yeah who was the
CTO of Microsoft
left around then to go be to take over
Baidu but weren't especially worried
just because when it was the first no
before it was the first announced it was
called Skype teams and had a pretty
different approach and it was just so
far behind us from a product perspective
that we weren't worried about people
switching ok so now in 2020 how do you
feel about Microsoft's team at it got a
lot better as Microsoft I think there's
there's a bunch of things that that make
it much more of a challenge for us today
than it was then and it's not just that
it's better because it's actually not
better enough compared to how it was
that any of our large customers could
could switch to it like our biggest
single user is IBM somewhere close to
300 thousand daily active users over
10,000 workspaces and teams is limited
to 5,000 users per workspace and you
can't federate them together so there's
be no way to support that kind of
structure so wouldn't work for them and
there's many other things that are not
very very fundamental limitation so for
5,000 people you can have 200 channels
if you want to add a 200 first you have
to hard delete one with all of the
messages but none of that really matters
in the face of if you want to be able to
collaborate on a word doc like with
track changes and and send it back and
forth your boy is working on a contract
or marketing people working on a press
release and you are an office 365
customer you more or less have to use
teams now and the hundred million users
of Skype for business are being migrated
over to two teams because Skype for
business is being shut down so there's a
bunch of things that are kind of force
it but maybe the most fundamental is we
have 12 million I don't even remember
what our public number is on daily
active users 12 yeah okay so 12 Ain and
there's at least 200 million people for
whom [ __ ] or something like it is is the
preferred way to work so 200 people
who's working lives are mediated by
email and they're moving over I think is
inevitable um so that's six percent
which means 94 percent of people don't
use it yet and if you don't use it and
you don't have any idea and and you hear
that there's two alternatives one slack
and ones teams and because you're an
office 365 customer teams is already
free and integrated with all the
Microsoft tools then why would you give
an evaluate slack or Microsoft was you
know aggressive in a way that was it was
surprising to a lot of people even who
watch the company closely like putting
out a press release what our daily
active users in it
during our quiet period post the listing
but if they can put a press release in
tank or share price then and you're not
watching this stuff very closely you
don't have a fighting degree of
resolution then you might think as a
customer why would I invest in the slack
and I think you know there's gonna be
out of business in three years like
Microsoft's gonna inevitably kill them
that doesn't waste of my time to even
look at it and it's not like at that
point the fact that they're different
really matters to you because you don't
use either and it's not really replacing
anything so it's much more of a thread
now I think we underestimated the degree
of importance like the Financial Times
Person of the Year was such a novella
and so there's a big write-up of that
and there's six consecutive paragraphs
that are about slack and there's like
there's no other look maybe the names of
some competitive companies are mentioned
in one sentence here and there but like
it's it's the the biggest chunk of it
and so I think that's because of all the
things that can be used as as leverage
by Microsoft to expand relationships
inside businesses exchange the the email
server and the fact that people are very
used to Outlook is like the principal
one that that kind of gets them in and
that makes it difficult for people to
switch and if people stop paying
attention to email email declines in
relative importance compared to the
other software you use that's a really
difficult position for them so for from
their perspective I think and this is
what Qi Liu thought back like 2016 this
is reflects successful to the to the
maximum extent that's an existential
threat to Microsoft I don't think that's
actually true because so many things so
many other things would change in the
world on the path to that but I think
there is a that is a thought process
hmm so despite selling out and actually
becoming a consultant I studied
mechanical engineering and undergrad and
as a black engineer I really appreciate
what slack has been doing on from the
perspective of diversity inclusion back
in 2015 slack shared anniversary report
which revealed that most of their black
employees were in tech
rolls contrasted with a lot of companies
that will hire black individuals
primarily into administrative roles and
in that same report 45 percent of
managers or female females so to a room
full of individuals who will start
companies or be at companies what advice
you have for creating diverse workplaces
um start early I think that's the
biggest thing when we were 20 employees
I would say I mean 20 and 30 maybe like
wow there's a lot of white kids and in
that case it wasn't too late but it was
close to too late you know it was like
more of a slog to get started because
what happened was you we have one black
woman engineer and then someone another
one comes to interview and she sees the
first one and suddenly it's like a
completely different assessment of
what's going on here and then there's
two and then the third one comes from
you and look it feels like there's
community and people talk and have a
have a network so that getting started
early I think is the most important
thing I think it can be a kind of a
fraught topic I think for me black
people aren't sure what to say or
they're uncomfortable and I think
there's a really pervasive and incorrect
belief that you would have to lower the
bar to hire someone who isn't but the
canonical candidate look the archetypal
candidate for this role I think that's
usually not the truth for two reasons
one is you just have to look harder
you're gonna see more people and in fact
that can raise the bar but people have
different challenges in their life and I
don't think you can you know perfectly
understand someone's back from just from
their gender
identity or their their ethnicity but on
the whole - for a woman to get to a
certain place in her career dad to work
a lot harder than man for a black
engineer to get to a certain place in
his or her career dad to work a lot
harder than this is where it gets fraud
and ben horowitz his words Jewish
Chinese or Indian guys in Silicon Valley
because there's just like these these
networks that are that are very powerful
and you have a enormous advantage so for
two people with like equivalent
credentials the person who is probably
going to be more talented more capable
and had to overcome more obstacles to
get to where they are is gonna be the
one who doesn't have the traditional
archetypal presentation oh it's amazing
thank you for sharing that I'm sure I
hope people were taking notes so we've
gone through the journey of your career
you started as a web developer you found
in a company that you that was acquired
by Yahoo you launched a second company
that raised more than 1.2 billion
dollars in venture funding and you
eventually took that company public
you've been a leader throughout this
entire time what has changed about your
leadership style and what stayed the
same so it's always hard to relate to to
assess yourself I think I'm relatively
self-aware even of those things that
don't work and it doesn't matter that I
know that they don't work I still can't
change them but there is a difference in
the mechanics of being a leader at
different scales because when it's 20
people and we all kind know each other
it's very different like my I say
something and then we argue about it and
it's all good you know there's a power
dynamic where I'm the CEO and whoever
and everyone else does not the CEO but
when you get to 500 people or a thousand
people where we're at now a couple
thousand people do very different the
someone going to come into a
presentation
for some new product development and
it's like a relatively new designer or
engineer or product manager we've never
met before
to me this is just like one more
30-minute meeting and my schedule which
is jig and for them this is something
they've been thinking about for weeks
like I would probably talk to their
spouse about in there either excited or
they're nervous they want to know so the
degree of impact that my words have is
like from the perspective of me rasie
out of proportion to the amount of
action so in other words like there's
it's like a super super powerful
microphone on at all the time so if
anything's negative or critical if I
have a relationship with someone then we
work together for a long time it's not
really a big deal if it's someone that
you know that might be the only time
they interact with me ever in their
whole career it's like or more like you
know it might be the first interaction
they've ever had with me and it might
not have another one for several years
it carries a huge amount of weight so
it's hard because is that's the amount
of time we have like including questions
from everyone that is okay I'll try to
be a little bit more concise every
reading on Twitter people arguing about
Warren's tax plan and someone said
something like if Dwayne the rock
Johnson just paid this tax at this rate
then we would have an extra 50 million
dollars and then that's how much it
would cost to to to solve the Flint
water crisis and it struck me as just a
totally absurd argument because federal
budget is something like 2.7 trillion
dollars so 50 million bucks plus or
minus is not the reason why that doesn't
get solved it doesn't get solved for all
kinds of reasons and people think that
way all the time that it's just like
money or it's just resources for
anything significant to happen certainly
anything involved dozens of people let
alone hundreds or thousands
the amount of will that has to go in the
amount of like selling the amount of
vision the amount of like coercion and
cajoling and the amount of encouragement
and support all of those things is just
enormous so the game does change as the
company gets bigger and things evolve
and I think probably only gets more
difficult but that's you know what I've
been learning this whole time is is how
to do that without like crushing people
how to do that without creating an
environment where it's entirely top-down
like Iron Fist from above and it can be
tough because you know I have a
different perspective than anyone else
because I see everything since I talked
to someone in engineering I get you know
that head of sales reports to me head of
marketing reports to me had a financier
points to me or general council reports
to me I have a very different
perspective than what is ultimately
relatively narrow and generally a better
idea but we also talk to customers more
than pretty much anyone else other than
a salesperson and I talk to our
investors more than anyone else not to
our board more than anyone else
yes it's really you know though I think
there are better sources than me for
lack top 10 tips' because I don't none
of them seem that simple to me and it's
not that they're not out there but the
real challenge of leadership or maybe
there's one book I would recommend which
is leadership and self-deception the
real like fundamental challenge
leadership is is the same as the
fundamental challenge of just being a
human being and I think that's so sound
a little bit weird perhaps but like
living with an open heart and not seeing
other people as on one hand either
instruments that can be used to your
advantage or obstacles that are in the
way of something that you're trying to
do which is the the kind of default
judgment of all people with whom you are
not close instinctually so like you're
on a Southwest flight and there's like
people are still boarding and the middle
seat between you hasn't taken you're
like please don't take the seat please
don't take the seat there's nothing to
see a person has a whole life you know
and their own ambitions and desires and
partakes and stuff like that but to you
in that moment they're just a potential
pain in the ass that might take the
middle seat next to you and that that's
pervasive and when you're really trying
to accomplish something it can be very
tempting to see people either as
instruments or obstacles so we're gonna
go through the audience for we probably
have a time for about two questions hi
Stuart um really appreciate your
comments on diversity so it makes me
feel better about my Stanford slack
addiction my question is what were some
of the key and best things you did on
the product and design front in the
early days of slack so for example how
much of slack success do you attribute
to your personal life or design versus
hiring the best designers versus feature
prioritization or or even just the
insight about having a personality
curious what advice you'd share there
for aspiring entrepreneurs yeah so I'm
not sure I want to like slice it up by
who gets more credit but I think the
fundamental approach was how much easier
can we make people's lives and when I
look at other products that's really the
I don't I'm trying to get like the
shortest version of this again it can be
an amazing app and if the password reset
thing doesn't work and I'm need to reset
my password to use it then I'm just
locked out so there's like there's very
basic fundamental things that you can
you have to get right and which aren't
the interesting ones in fact someone
tweeted something the other day which I
liked that kind of illustrates this from
a different perspective and it's someone
asking Ray Kroc the kind of founder and
first CEO of McDonalds why was McDonald
so successful and he says because we
have clean bathrooms and they say that's
easy you know that's so simple I don't
that doesn't explain it and rank
said are your bathrooms clean and it
actually is like a challenge so there's
some some real fundamentals but the
things that we did that were most
successful were those things which made
life more convenient for people and one
of those was for example typing your
password on your phone is a pain so
we'll send you a magic link that logs
you in or because for complex reasons
most people wanted to have notifications
or every message and slack when they
first signed up so they felt comfortable
and knew how it worked but we didn't
think that was a good way for them to
set their preferences long-term after
you know a few notifications we would
interject and say would you like to
switch to our preferred settings and
that kind of thoughtfulness or
consideration that kind of being
thinking of yourself as a host and the
customers as your guests I think is the
the secret as it were to a good design
we have time for one more question
uh can you hear me yeah thank you so
much for taking the time to speak with
us today so in your answers it was
really clear that what you've been
interested in is kind of facilitating
communication through different mediums
whether it be video games photography
you know now slack was that
understanding clear to you through your
journey and if not was there like an aha
moment that you realized this is what
the issue you really wanted to work on
was yeah I don't know so if the desire
was there but I don't think I recognize
that is as one single thing because
slack is also a massively multiplayer
work by software yeah that's the kind of
the the principal distinction between
slack can pretty much every other tool
and it is very much like the games that
we wanted to play it could take objects
and you can manipulate them and
distribute them and form groups and and
all of that I don't think they really
recognize them as being fundamentally
similar until much later the thing that
I thought as being the common thread was
just it's all software and software that
groups that people use together to me is
the most interesting challenges because
it has all the regular challenges of
scalability on the one hand and design
and usability on the other
but social dynamics because of the
feedback we wear the output of the
system can also be an input to the
system are much more difficult to to
design for and therefore much more
interesting amazing thank you all for
the questions Dharma you had a pleasure
chatting with you it's not often that we
get time with a classically-trained
philosophers so I have a new spin on our
typical lightning round I'm gonna ask
you a few questions that keep me up at
night is that ok cool so we'll start
with an easy one is water wet yes ok if
soap hits the floor is the floor clean
or is it so dirty so sturdy yeah
dirty soap alright I have to make sure I
pronounce this one the right way as
expecting the unexpected make the
unexpected expected no no we're going No
ok final one you ready one word or less
what is the meaning of life oh I thought
the question was one word or less for
those of you who read visage that are
familiar with the history of Buddhism
I'll say Moo Moo we have a minute and 20
seconds so I would love to hear more
it's funny there is like a like I said
before contemporary anglo-american
philosophy is really boring
on the one hand and you take away a
subject matter there are there's an
enormous corpus of research and argument
and even books written but certainly
like thousands of papers on the question
of do holes exist like hol e like is
there such a thing as a hole or is it
the absence of something unless I swear
that is a giant argument so I find
easier just to come down on the side of
one or the other the meaning of life
to love one another okay I like that one
ladies and gentlemen Stewart Butterfield
[Applause]
[Music]